So now, we're going to move on to night terrors. This occurs most often in
childhood and results in waking from sleep in a terrified state. Most of these
occur in the first third of the night. Now, if this happens, the person might
be difficult to comfort because they're going to be thrashing around violently.
This could last 10 to 20 minutes and then, they'll fall back asleep.
Oftentimes, the person will have no memory of the event and can't explain what
happened the following morning. Now, some people with night terrors, also sleep
walk in which they engage in behaviors they would do while they're awake. Even
though they're asleep. For example, this could include eating, getting dressed,
moving furniture, or even driving a car while asleep. Now, sleepwalking can
occur in children and adults. About 4 to 15% of children sleepwalk, and about
1.5 to 2.5% of adults sleepwalk. Now let's go to my friend who has night
terrors, and let's see what he has to say about it.